mommy's gonna be shallow the president
stood in silent contemplation at
berlin's kun ova train station during
the Nazi era this was a departure point
for tens of thousands of Jews sent to
ghettos and concentration camps it was a
simple and moving ceremony Rivlin told
those in attendance that the cruelty of
the past provides an important lesson
for the present and the future the
battle against racism anti-semitism and
fundamentalism requires us to be alert
to end decisive we must remember
democracy alone does not make as us
immune to nationalism and fascism
the harmonious diplomatic relationship
between Germany and Israel was a long
time in the making in 1965 wolf Palace
became the first German ambassador to
Israel his arrival was met with angry
protests west german chancellor konrad
adenauer an Israeli Prime Minister David
ben-gurion worked behind the scenes for
years to establish relations trade and
deals to deliver weapons to Israel led
to closer ties rivlin expressed hope
that the Alliance will grow even
stronger in the years to come the issue
of Palestine also came up yeah we are
committed to the process of implementing
the two-state solution resume from boy
water faith but we are also aware of
Israel's serious misgivings on the issue
Riven's official visit continues on
Tuesday when he's due to meet with
Chancellor young lemare chol